buildings on fire in puana pitre in the
caribbean archipelago of guadalupe this
is french overseas territory and after
nearly a week of civil unrest here the
government in paris is sending
reinforcements
on top of the 200 extra personnel
already in place 50 police special
forces have just arrived these pictures
are from a local news channel
[Applause]
a nighttime curfew was imposed on friday
but it hasn't brought calm more than 30
people were arrested that night alone
we've ascertained not only that there is
disorder but that live ammunition was
used against law enforcement officers
looting is now taking place at the
island which has if i may say so nothing
to do with the covet protest
trade unions in guadalupe started an
indefinite strike on monday they're
angry about the compulsory vaccination
of health workers against covid19 and
about the french health pass which is
required to access restaurants and cafes
cultural venues sports arenas and long
distance travel
because of this criminal anti-social law
which they set up hundreds of workers
are being thrown onto the street and by
extension thousands of people because
behind each salaried employee there's a
family
the french government says about 80
percent of health care workers in
guadalupe have already been vaccinated
it also says road blockades have
disrupted supplies to hospitals
blame those who made vaccination
compulsory you can't do that and then
suspend staff without salary they're
affected morally and physically and 50
of staff are suspended so vaccinated
staff will be doing double the work
the local authority says some electrical
facilities near dams have been damaged
causing power outages to some areas
french prime minister jean castex is set
to meet guadalupe officials on monday to
discuss the crisis
nadim baba al-jazeera